so as a stand-up comedian I'm on the
road quite a bit and I stay in more than
my fair share of hotels I don't know if
you've ever noticed this but in the
bathroom of hotels now they have these
signs that say we care about the
environment a towel on the floor means
please replace a towel on the rack means
I'll use it again please be green reuse
your towel I don't know about you but
whenever I see something like this I
always feel like they're trying to get
away with something you know what I mean
like they're not being straight with me
and I had the sassiest reaction in my
brain just like alone in my bathroom
just like excuse me oh hell no you keep
a 3-foot high six foot wide walk in
fireplace in your Lobby burning 12 logs
of freshly chopped timber all goddamn
night just so you can give your hotel a
homey feel and you want me to be green
how about this homey get a bucket fill
it with water put out the fire refill
that bucket and use the water to wash my
damn cows
this is the bet so let me get this
straight you cover my bed with 40
decorative pillows and I'm just gonna
throw 39 of them on the floor so I can
fit in the goddamn bed and then you have
to wash all 40 of them just so the next
guest can throw those clean
on the ground too
how about this next time you do your
huge unnecessary pillow wash why don't
you stop by my bathroom first so you can
watch my damned ass that's right
and it's not just hotels wash my damn
towels is the best phrase for anything
whenever you're tired of getting
from something wash my damn towels is
always there for you
check it out like uh hey cats that's
right hey cats you're distant aloof you
hide when I come home and run away when
I try to pet you but you expect me to
feed you shelter you and be cool with
you destroying my couch and my rug I got
an idea whenever you're done filling my
apartment with your pungent urine smell
why don't you stick out your little
sandpaper tongue and wash my damn towel
hey Steve Urkel
that's right Steve goddamn Urkel let me
get this straight you made a machine
that transformed you from a nerd into a
cool guy named stefan urquelle and you
kept that to yourself not helping
your fellow nerds out just selfishly
using it to try and floor.a Winslow and
still failing how about this put down
the cheese admit you did do that and was
my damn house
this is the actual stage they filmed
family matters on - so not the first
time that's happened folks my uncle
Larry is in the audience tonight and he
loves this bit so I'd love to invite him
up on stage if he doesn't mind
yeah show me your shirt
so uncle Larry is out visiting from
Boston yeah how's it go I'm eatin is
that bad I wish you would yeah
so hilari uncle is that better yeah as
as good as it gonna get this is my
wonderful uncle Larry he's currently
going through chemotherapy for bone
cancer he loves this bit so we thought
we would do a very special wash madam
towels with you if that's okay
final man great everyone
uh hey cancer
that's right cancer yeah you uninvited
you make people feel bad make
them go through chemotherapy and you try
and crush their spirits make a nauseous
we said hell no we got our family we got
our friends and we're gonna with or
without you have a happy life so how
about this
get out of my uncle come yourself
wash my damn towels